说下我的情况，
我的情况是这样的，
我跟我老公也是那种裸婚，
就是之前也是白手起家的那种，
然后嗯，
在重庆买了一套商品房，
然后买了之后呢，
我觉得那个小了，
我就卖了，
和商量之后我就卖了，
卖了之后呢，
然后我老公他就把那个钱呢，
他就当时卖的是60万，
卖了之后，
然后他就放了10万在身上，
他父母就叫他回来在农村的宅基地上面修房子，
用来做做那个民宿，
相当于本来一楼有房，
然后又在二楼上面重了一层啊，
当时我就以为好像是他的父母就是修房子叫他回去帮忙，
然后呢，
后来他修房子呢，
就动用了我们这个就是买房的钱，
因为他当时走了嘛，
也没跟我商量，
他就说离婚就是离婚他也要修那个房子，
就是修那个农村宅基地二楼的房子，
一楼本来是爸爸的户主，
是爸爸的，
修了之后又租了一套，
租了一套，
后来他说他想租一套，
又没有钱，
我又把钱给他打回去了，
相当于我也拿了一半的钱给他，
相当于现在我还剩了大概30万在手上，
另外30万是拿给他的，
就是他修他个农村宅基地的房子。
用于做民宿，
然后呢，
我现在就是说在他这边呢，
生活呢很不习惯，
因为本来之前和那个就是婆媳关系也不是很好，
还有一个问题就是公公呢，
也有点性格比较暴躁，
那种易怒的那种感觉，
就是随时都拿菜出来，
有几次还是我们客人下来抢的那个菜，
就是这种情况，
嗯，
还有一个吧，
我老公呢，
他平时性格也比较那种暴躁，
一冒火的话就喜欢打狗这些，
我就我现在就是很纠结我的这个婚姻我应该怎么办，
然后婆婆呢，
也喜欢挑事儿，
就是她父亲和他的关系，
因为他们我回来之后看到他们经常都在，
就是吵架呀，
就是父亲一冒火就把菜刀弄出来呀，
这种现在就很纠结，
我这个婚姻我我要不要继续下去，
我本来想着我肯定是不愿意在这里住了，
然后我老公的意思就是他的意思就是说我可以去买房子，
但是呢，
他不愿意承担房贷，
然后我肯定想着我肯定是要自己去买，
我我也他不愿意承担房贷就算了，
我就自己承担吧，
我就这样想的，
我现在主要纠结的问题是这个意思，
就是说我的老公呢，
他那个就是从结婚开始，
他的情绪啊，
很易怒，
就是随时都发发脾气，
前些年呢，
因为他生病了，
我就。
让着他，
那后来我发现他一直都是这个样子，
就是脾气性格很易怒哈，
还有一个问题就是他很自私，
他很多问题他都只考虑他自己，
本来他回来修房子我是不同意的，
因为刚刚疫情过后，
生意也不太好做，
我是不同意他回来说他硬着头皮非要回来修，
修到半途没有钱了，
打电话叫我打钱回来，
我也没办法，
他自己又放了10万在手上，
钱放在我手上他不放心，
就是一共60万，
他放了10万走，
然后我身上有50万，
就算他不放心，
放在我这里修了，
又都没有钱了，
我也没办法，
你俩有还过吗？
有多大了，
四岁了，
你俩主要是靠他挣钱还是靠你挣钱？
之前主要是靠我挣钱，
我开店的之前就是说嫁到这个家，
基本上就是裸婚，
什么都没有，
然后主要是靠我自己去做生意赚钱，
就赚的钱买的房，
之前的情况就这种，
然后孩子呢，
婆婆也没有带孩子，
都是我姑妈帮我带的，
我拿钱我们家之前主要是靠我打拼，
然后现在就是说我身体也比较差，
因为就是怄气怄的太多了，
还有一个问题就是和我老公的这个关系呢，
我不知道怎么说，
就是我感觉她很自私，
她做什么事情她不考虑我的感受，
因为本来我第一我是不同意她回来就是修这个房子的，
因为。
对，
当时卖的时候我们就说好了是拿来就是换房，
我都去看房子了，
看了很多次都等着他回来，
就是大家一起商量买，
但是呢，
他没回来，
他一走就是一年，
就是回老家这边来修房子嘛，
修他的二楼做民宿营，
也知道是他的名字，
但是副主的是他爸爸的名字，
后来我又回来了，
他叫我女儿也跟着回来，
我也跟着回来，
我想算了，
以前的事情就不计较了，
回来把孩把女儿也弄在一起回来，
我也回来，
我想算了一下的，
我回来之后，
我又用了10万块钱，
就是支持他的事业嘛，
之前他说意是说我没有支持他事业，
我说我这次确实是真心实在的支持你的事业，
而且就是自己去买菜，
煮一大家人做做的饭，
然后我婆婆呢，
就是那种一点亏都不想吃，
煮好了之后她连碗都不想洗，
我现在就是感觉我在这里生活很累，
现在我感觉就很痛苦，
我想的我肯定是不能和他们生活在一起的，
就是之前在重庆的时候，
我老员工他也把他提出来的，
我就搞不懂这种是怎么怎么个情况，
就是说是这个性格，
像这个样子，
这种我还能不能继续下去过，
能不能继续过这个事儿啊，
最终决定权还是要回到你的手里，
我只能从一个律师的角度。
帮你分析一下你的利弊，
帮你分析一下你在这段婚姻里面有什么隐患，
有什么吃亏的地方好不好？
从法律上来讲的话，
你看啊，
你主要是家里挣钱的，
然后你们当时卖了一套房子，
是婚内的房子，
那你卖了这套房子得到这60万呢，
法律上叫夫妻共同财产，
那这60万现在已经有30万，
他拿去他的老家，
是由他爸爸的那个房子的二层了，
他爸爸那个房子的二层权利，
从产权上来说的话，
那就是他爸爸的，
他是那个农村的宅基地，
农村宅基地是他爸爸名下的，
那个房子就是他爸爸的，
他修到二层的话，
你俩如果说分手的话，
这个是不可能判给你的，
你知道吗？
也就是说某种程度上来说的话，
你们总共60万的共同财产，
他已经拿出30万过去贴到他爸爸那个房子上去了啊，
营业执照是他的，
只是他注册的那个旅馆的营业执照而已，
但是那个房子你是分不了的，
基本上可以那么说，
那现在你手上假设还剩30万的话，
我认为啊，
假设要你现在要打着要分开的这样一个主意的话，
那你应该是这30万保证是你的，
你才不吃亏，
否则的话，
你这30万还得分10万给他，
因为那个钱已经花掉了，
花掉。
的钱就不是你们夫妻共同的财产了，
这个钱不管是花到哪儿啊，
那个什么吃饭了也好，
就旅游了也好，
老人生病了也好，
对吧，
孩子上学了也好，
这钱花掉了就是花掉了，
就不再是你们夫妻共同的财产了，
哦，
这个我明白了，
但是他现在目前还有贷款，
他还有13万的贷款，
就是他回来修房子还贷着个钱，
去年已经给他还了7万左右，
去年回来的时候欠了20万的账，
我已经在还了7万，
还有13万的账。
本来你看你自己啊，
你拿的剧本是属于大女主的剧本，
为啥你自己是能开店，
能做老板娘，
能经营的，
你自己是能挣钱吗？
那你就放弃了自己的领地，
放弃了自己那个相当于是城里面城市里面的那个钱吧，
有如说你跑到这个农村来了，
是这样的，
就是罗菲利，
是因为我是之前太劳累了，
就是说生病了，
然后回来想休养一年，
确实是生病了，
我的店面已经拿给我弟弟在做，
每个月大概能赚2万块钱，
这个样子，
我拿给我弟弟在做，
然后我就回来养病嘛，
嗯，
太操劳了，
这些年太累了，
再加上又生气，
身多了全身的毛病，
然后就想自己休息一下，
他想着休息吧，
回到这里还一天有气氛，
感觉这里不是养生的地方，
我现在就是。
我不是说纠结这个钱，
我觉得钱丢了我可以再挣，
我身体身体比较差，
我把身体养好了，
我可以再挣这个钱，
我是想表达的意思是说这种老公的话有没有必要，
就是说继续下去，
他从来不在乎我的感受，
就是说为了房子重新买，
商量好了的有变卦，
就是说承诺的事情从来都是达不到，
我给你看一下正常人的思维啊，
就是我直播间1.3万人就正常，
一个女人在你的这个状态下，
自己又能挣钱，
把自己的生活安排的很好，
老公背着你去，
不跟你商量，
就去他的老家，
在他的父亲的房子上盖房子，
然后现在装修还欠那么多钱，
而且你老公最关键的是脾气不可控，
动不动就是打狗啊，
就是拿啊什么的啊，
就你这种情况下，
你你自己看啊，
直播间1.3万人，
如果让你们选，
你们会做出什么样的选择，
是继续跟他过，
还是自己独善其身，
自己哪怕是回到你自己工作的城市啊，
你休息一段时间，
休养一段时间，
嗯，
自己报点什么跳操啊，
辅导啊，
健身班啊，
把自己的身体养好，
或者自己回娘家，
有一个好的心情，
把自己的身体养好是排在第一位的啊，
你自己看啊，
看评论区啊，
我说意思就是我想说一下就是。
是，
他是因为他的父亲喜欢拿拿那个菜刀，
他没有，
就是说他就喜欢打狗，
就是很暴力那种打狗，
弄得现在我非常的纠结，
但是结婚这么多年了，
他对我呢，
不是很关心，
就是他所有的东西就想到他自己，
就是很自私，
做事情都想到自己，
他不考虑我的感受，
也不考虑我的意见，
相当于是这个意思，
目前还贷款还没有还完的情况下，
还想继续去投，
就说还想在这个农村的宅基地上面，
还想去投钱，
并且叫我不要管，
就是这个弄得我就很被动，
如果啊，
假设有这个机会的话，
我建议你还是跟他签个协议，
就是说剩下的30万存款是归你个人单独所有的，
不是夫妻共同的财产，
然后他名下的债务是他个人的债务，
不是夫妻共同的债务啊，
我就说我应该怎么做，
对我自己的话，
利益比较好一点嘛，
就是说这样这种情况下的话，
像我刚才说的这么多，
对你利益保护好一点，
债务是他自己的债务，
然后剩下的存款是你个人的存款，
不是夫妻共同财产，
要公平一点，
之前我也问他们，
他们就说就是说这边二楼修的房子我也有一半，
但是我有一半我拿来干嘛呢？
我又拿不走对吧，
我又不在这里住，
有什么意义呢？
没有意义的，
我会判给你的。
因为一楼的宅基地是你公公的二楼的房子，
他们就想着叫我还要在这里给他们还贷款，
在这里做生意帮着做，
然后出钱出力的帮着做，
但是呢，
又没我的份儿，
现在他们想是这样想的，
但是我我现在我不愿意了，
你的这个情况最主要是剩下的手上的30万存款要保住了，
归你一个人啊，
债务归他啊，
好，
谢谢哈，
董菲利是首先啊，
就是这十几年了，
对吧，
孩子都十几岁了，
这十几年了，
已经社会给你验证过了，
他赚钱能力就约等于没有嘛，
都是靠你养家嘛，
虽然说这个社会上啊，
大家也听过这种传奇的故事，
比如说李安导演，
他可能在很多年他没有工作，
都是他老婆养着他，
然后他呃后来当导演很成功，
也愿意跟他的老婆去分享他的荣耀，
也是没有抛弃他的糟糠之妻，
但是这个世界上又有几个人是李安导演呢？
我这么讲就想告诉大家，
有很多东西的话，
是我们不能赌那样的小概率事件的，
如果说这个社会用10年甚至用20年的时间帮你检验过一个人，
这个人就是干啥啥不行，
干啥都挣不着钱，
干啥都不成功，
不要轻易被像别人导演这样的故事所激励啊，
不要轻易拿自己的人生去赌那种小概率事件，
我觉得可能我没有那么好的运气，
我没有那么好的运气说能够遇到一个啊，
40岁了干啥啥不成，
然后突然45岁了之后，
就一下子就就就能力就爆发了，
我可能觉得自己这辈子都没有这么好的运气吧，
所以我不会拿自己的生命去下这个赌注。